la france de nouveau sous la canicule
vous en êtes forcément aperçu toutes les
régions sont touchées par cette vague de
chaleur qui fait souffrir notamment les
bébés et les personnes âgées
cet après midi les températures ont
dépassé les 40 degrés à l'ombre dans le
sud ouest
le thermomètre a même affiché 44 degrés
à albi dans le tarn reportage de
benjamin fleurot et frédéric beth albi
écrasée de chaleur la canicule est
toujours là les habitants de la cité
tarnaise passent leur temps à se
désaltérer
il est vrai qu'avec une température de
44 degrés il y a un réel risque de
déshydratation
à commencer par les nouveaux nés il ya
quelque chose qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est de les hydrater très très
régulièrement
or les conseils c'est d'éviter
effectivement toute activité entre 10 et
17 heures quand il s'agit d'une activité
ludique bord de piscine très très
vigilant attentif et surtout utilisé le
chapeau le tee shirt et les cram écran
total à la maison de retraite de goode à
albi les personnes âgées doivent
également boire suffisamment
ce qu'elles ne pensent pas toujours à
faire c'est revoir les personnes âgées
c'est difficile puisqu'ils perdent peu à
peu la sensation de soif mais en les
faisant boire régulièrement
c'est bon ensuite allégé les vêtements
bien sûr fermez les volets le matin les
fenêtres dès que le soleil arrive et par
compte ouvrir tout grand la nuit
provient laisser rentrer la fraîcheur
des volets clos pour se protéger de la
chaleur torride beaucoup d'albigeois
avaient déserté la ville pour aller au
bord de l'eau sauf quelques-uns qui ont
profité des bienfaits de la fontaine de
la place du vigan
une peine qui devrait se répéter ces
prochains jours la canicule est encore
prévue